[MUSIC PLAYING]
- One of the things
I'm hoping to learn is,
are their actual solutions that
can be found in some of the new
philosophy, the new poetry, and
the new novels called cli-fi?
Cli-fi mean, simply,
climate fiction.
It actually is a vast array
of different kinds of literary
products, everything from
memoirs that have some kind
of emphasis on climate change,
so not necessarily fictive,
maybe fictive elements
as all memoir has,
to novels to youth
fictions-- oh,
there's a great YA series
of fictions out there that,
in various respects,
touch on climate change--
to film.
So climate fiction is a
very broad multimedia,
multigenre project that
many artists and filmmakers
and authors have been
pursuing in an attempt
to tell the story
of climate change.
My own feeling is
that cli-fi could
be a much more capacious term.
I don't really
understand the distancing
that some authors take from it.
But I'm respectful of it.
Other terms that have
come into being beside it
include Anthropocene
fiction, looking
at the moment of
the Anthropocene
when we really see
ourselves driving
global climate, global
geology, and taking reflection
on that in fictional forms.
Solar punk is another
movement that's
a relatively young movement
that's very positive
and has a lot of focus on
technological solutions
at the local level.
I associate that with
youth maker culture,
looking at kind of local
solutions, local energy grids,
ways of creating
autonomous functioning
systems if the larger structures
of society break down.
Climate fiction to me is
about loving the world,
about not being afraid to
continue to love the world,
even in a moment
of mass extinction.
And it's also about
salvaging ourselves
as a species, by which I mean
remaking ourselves in a way
that I hope means a more sound,
sustainable, and just future.
[MUSIC PLAYING]